okay now let's break up the demographic
in the geographic segments so the
demographic segmentation is you guessed
it based on your customers demographic
characteristics things like age gender
occupation education level income level
and much more if you're coming from a
b2b or business-to-business point of
view this could be the size of the
company the number of employees or even
the location of the company now for the
geographic segmentation this is just
segmented by geographic areas such as
the country regions different cities
postal codes now you can do a geo
cluster approach which combines
demographic and geographic segmentations
you'll look at different demographic
information within a certain area to
create a more specific profile
Geographic segmentation is really
important for international marketing
it's usually your first step so an
example of a geographic segmentation
would be warm climates versus cold
climates
now you're probably better off marketing
the coats you make to a cooler climate
than you are to a warmer climate just as
bathing suits might not sell as well and
Alaska as they would in Brazil or the
Caribbean